voici ce que Squeezie pense de Cyprien
coucou Lucas alors moi je voulais savoir
si tu considérais Cyprien comme ton
mentor merci de ta réponse grave ouais
grave Cyprien c'est quelqu'un auprès de
qui j'ai évolué pendant des années et
quand j'étais très jeune j'avais 17 ans
et pour la petite histoire il m'a
peut-être qu' y a des gens qui savent
pas il m'avait contactter pour faire une
chaîne gaming avec lui Cyprien gaming
qu'on a fait pendant des années et qui
m'a apporté alors d'un côté oui
énormément de visibilité mais surtout de
l'autre ça m'a surtout apporté le fait
d'être au côté du mec de l'époque qui
est le plus fort sur Youtube et de loin
qui était le premier youtubeur qui était
le premier youtubeur et j'ai eu beaucoup
de chance d'ailleurs d'avoir eu cette
formation entre guillemets privilégiée
sur et notre métier et la vie
globalement auprès de lui tu vois
c'était c'était incroyable